because I read their policy volleyball
England welcomes and supports all
coaches officials and volunteers who
identify as transgender and does not
tolerate any transphobic if the behavior
and actions a volleyball England member
employee are offensive towards any trans
person volleyball England will
investigate the matter and we're
appropriate discipline the club or
individual according to the code of
conduct and disciplinary policy so this
person says if you are able so I said
what is what is what is transphobic I'm
I'm okay so he said if if you're able to
see the tweet from the perspective of
trans person you will feel that will you
feel the organization was welcoming um
so I said so it's based on how the
transgender person feels and I'd like to
clarify the policy because volleyball
England if you look up their policy on
this it's very vague um they say during
regular season they don't allow trans
people in but then we're at the
tournament when I asked the director of
the tournament he said that trans people
were in the League this year I guess I
didn't notice 30